bien mes chers collègues
nous accueillons donc ce matin Monsieur
Bruno Lasserre
je rappelle que nous sommes saisis mais
je viens de vous le dire dans le cas des
dispositions l'article 13 de la
Constitution
monsieur le Président la serre est
proposé par le Président de la
République pour présider au destinées de
la CADA
nommé évidemment vous prendriez la
succession de Monsieur Névache je l'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure à nos collègues
j'indique à nos collègues avant de vous
laisser la parole que le vote aura lieu
à l'issue de votre audition que ce vote
naturellement est personnel il ne peut
pas y avoir de pouvoir et quand la
circonstances c'est la règle des trois
cinquièmes négatif qui s'applique je
crois que le dépouillement aura lieu
après puisque nous devons être en même
temps si je puis dire avec l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle aussi que cette
audition un caractère public et qu'elle
est ouverte à la presse
monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
me réjouis beaucoup d'être parmi vous ce
matin je l'ai déjà fait pour des
fonctions précédentes et je disais ce
matin à la semaine nationale que c'est
un moment important d'avoir pour la
République pour s'assurer que le
candidat proposé à l'Amérique les
qualités pour occuper le poste auquel il
se destinent mais aussi pour les
candidats eux-mêmes et j'ai trouvé très
souvent que c'était grâce aux questions
qui m'était posée autant qui m'était
imparti pour présenter mon projet que
c'est devant la présentation par le
ventaire que l'on réfléchit à ses
priorités que l'on construit en quelque
sorte le mandat que l'on va vous confier
que l'on peut comprendre aussi les
attentes les aspirations qui vous sont
transmises et donc je crois très très
importantes cette rencontre de ce matin
je voulais aussi dire que c'est d'autant
plus important que le Parlement et le
Sénat en particulier a joué un rôle
fondamental dans l'instauration de cette
transparence de cette liberté d'accès
aux documents administratifs on ne le
dit pas assez c'est une loi entièrement
d'initiative parlementaire que celle du
17 juillet
1978 elle a été inspirée conçue portée
adopté par la sommationale et le Sénat
alors que le gouvernement de l'époque ne
voulait pas de cette loi c'est vraiment
une loi d'inspiration parlementaire donc
inédite dans la manière dont elle a été
conçue et adoptée et très généreuse dans
les contours de cette nouvelle
transparence qu'elle dessine et je
voudrais rendre hommage en particulier
au sénateur Tirou qui était le
rapporteur de la commission des Lois du
Sénat qui a été l'un des principaux
artisans de cette loi qui l'a portée
avec beaucoup de convictions il disait
je m'en souviens
que avec cette loi arrivait l'air du
contrôle citoyen qui s'ajouterait au
contrôle hiérarchique et au contrôle
politique et il disait lui-même que
c'était l'avènement d'une société fondée
sur la considération et la confiance et
non pas sur le soupçon d'autres se
reconnaîtront ici dans le rôle qu'ils
ont joué dans cette loi cette nouvelle
qui m'a intéressé dès le début c'était
au moment juste où je rentrais au
Conseil d'État j'ai été intéressé par
cette cause et j'ai voulu rejoindre la
CADA dans les premiers mois où elle a
été constituée j'ai donc été rapporteur
dès 1979 puis rapporteur général pendant
trois ou quatre ans au tout début du
fonctionnement de la commission et
c'était un combat un combat à l'époque
l'administration disait nous
n'appliquerons pas cette loi nous ne
l'avons pas voulu elle n'est pas pour
nous et elle regrettait le temps où
chaque missionnaires pouvaient avec un
tampon rouge ou noir écrire confidentiel
secret sur les documents qu'il
produisait il a fallu faire œuvre de
pédagogie convaincre les administrations
surmonter les résistances et j'y ai pris
je le cache pas beaucoup d'intérêt au
point que plus tard lorsque je suis
revenu au Conseil d'État j'ai accepté de
présider par suppléance la CADA j'ai été
nommé membre pendant 4 ans ou 5 ans
alors que Michel pubasset la présidé et
ça m'a donné l'occasion de revenir sur
ce thème qui m'intéressait et de
présider les séances de la CADA lorsque
le président n'était pas disponible j'ai
laissé un peu de mon coeur je vous le
cache pas et je ne vous le dis très
nettement je serai très heureux
maintenant que j'ai plus de temps je
suis à la retraite depuis le mois de
janvier de me consacrer à nouveau à
cette cause qui m'intéresse
est-ce que tous les espoirs placés dans
la loi du 17 juillet 78 ont été remplies
non je ne serai pas honnête on vous
disant que oui la transparence a fait du
chemin nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
dans un paysage parfait et le seul fait
que la CADA statue chaque année sur
aujourd'hui
8500 demandes d'accès non satisfaites et
ne prononce que 12% d'avis défavorable
sur les avis qu'elle rend montre qu'il y
a beaucoup encore de refus d'accès
injustifiés qui viennent de la peur du
conflit de la crainte que le document
soit utilisé contre l'administration ou
la collectivité qui le détient tout
simplement aussi parce que chacun n'est
pas encore apprivoisé à cette société de
la transparence ou de la confiance
donc je vais essayer en quelques mots
parce que l'essentiel est de répondre à
vos questions expliquer selon moi
quelles sont les priorités que je
développerai à la tête de la CADA si le
mandat met confié d'abord disons-le il y
a des choses qu'ils peuvent être
améliorés qui ne dépendent pas seulement
de la CADA
avant de statuer sur les demandes
d'accès je crois surtout qu'il faut
développer et j'ai lu avec intérêt un
rapport du député bottorell sur ce sujet
il faut développer l'Open Data la loi
République numérique de 2016 à
imposer l'ouverture des données
publiques chaque fois que on est en
présence d'un intérêt économique social
sanitaire environnemental pour tous les
documents répertoriés dans les
répertoires que doivent tenir les
administrations ou les collectivités
soyons honnêtes on est très loin encore
de l'ouverture complète des données
beaucoup de collectivités n'ont pas
lancé ce chantier beaucoup de données ne
sont pas publiées et obligent les
citoyens à demander individuellement
accès à des documents qui normalement
devraient être publiés et donc en accès
libre les répertoires que administration
devrait publier pour savoir quelles sont
les documents qu'elles détiennent car
comment un citoyen peut savoir qu'un
document existe s'il n'est pas
répertorié dans un répertoire lui-même
ouvert au public beaucoup de ces
répertoires ne sont pas mis à la
disposition du public ou sont complets
les personnes responsables de l'accès
aux documents administratifs les Prada
qui doivent normalement être désignés
dans la plupart des administrations ou
des collectivités ne sont pas toujours
désignés et donc ces correspondants en
quelque sorte qu'ils doivent guider
accompagner les décideurs publics mais
aussi être l'interface avec le public ne
sont pas en mesure de jouer ce rôle de
prévention d'accompagnement du droit
d'accès il y a donc oui beaucoup à faire
j'ajoute à cela les délais qui ne sont
pas toujours compatibles avec les
besoins de ceux qui souhaitent accéder à
tel ou tel document administratif en cas
de scandale sanitaire ou environnemental
c'est dans l'immédiat que ces documents
devraient pouvoir être accessibles quand
ils sont refusés s'engagent de long
délai d'abord pour obtenir la
communication quand elle est refusée
saisir la CADA au terme de la loi la
CADA devrait rendre son avis en un mois
elle ne respecte pas aujourd'hui cet
objectif malgré les remarquables efforts
qui ont été faits ces deux dernières
années pour accélérer le traitement des
saisines on est passé de 182 jours en
moyenne à 82 jours donc la réduction est
drastique mais on n'est pas encore au
délai d'un mois qui est le standard
voulu par le législateur et lorsque
l'administration ne suit pas la vie
s'engage à nouveau un nouveau combat
pour les citoyens qu'il ne peut porter
infiner que devant le tribunal
administratif oui donc ça reste un long
combat
tout tout n'a pas changé tout n'est pas
parfait en même temps je vois des signes
positifs qui s'annoncent d'abord c'est
important la CADA qui je l'ai dit parmi
les plus de 8000 avis qu'elle rend ne
rend que 12% d'avis défavorable dans les
avis favorables qu'elle rend qui sont
donc la très majorité par la motivation
par la conviction l'explication qu'elle
met dans ses avis arrive souvent à
surmonter les obstacles
rencontrés par les citoyens je prends
l'exemple des cahiers citoyens remis par
justement les citoyens lors du grand
débat national qui a suivi la crise des
gilets jaunes
un journaliste a voulu accéder de
manière numérique à tous ces cahiers
citoyens pour comprendre l'état de la
société pour le mesurer pour voir
comment les citoyens interagissaient
avec les pouvoirs publics lors de ce
grand débat national cela était refusé
la CADA a expliqué que anonymiser
l'ensemble des données privées contenues
dans ces cahiers citoyens seraient une
tâche infaisable et que l'intérêt
journalistique la liberté d'informer
commander compte tenu de l'usage prévu
de cette communication de faire
prévaloir le droit d'accès sur la
protection du secret et bien cet avis a
réussi à surmonter les résistances
initiales du gouvernement puisque les
services du prémisse ont finalement
communiqué intégralement ses cahiers
citoyens c'est un progrès deuxième signe
positif sur lequel je ne m'a pas je
dirais pas longtemps mais que je
voudrais signaler la demande d'accès
change un peu de nature alors qu'au
départ et contrairement d'ailleurs à
l'intention initiale du législateur
c'était surtout les citoyens qui
demandaient accès au dossier individuel
les concernant dans une approche très
contentieuse ce qu'il voulait c'était
comprendre les motifs des décisions qui
leur étaient opposées sans doute
contester plus tard la décision qui
était prise à leur égard et donc
demander l'accès à tous les documents
qui avaient préparé la décision négative
qui leur était opposée donc c'est un peu
une phase prétentieuse dans un conflit
individuel entre un citoyen et une
administration depuis quelques années
le droit à la transparence est utilisé
par de nouvelles forces les militants
les journalistes les ONG les lanceurs
d'alerte les chercheurs qui utilisent
cette loi pour investiguer publié
contrôler l'action publique pour
utiliser en quelque sorte ce droit dans
l'idée pour lequel il a été construit
n'oublions pas que le droit d'accès aux
documents est devenu
constitutionnellement protégé depuis une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
d'avril 2020 il est aujourd'hui aussi
protégé par la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme et la Charte des
droits fondamentaux de l'Union
européenne parce qu'il est un auxiliaire
d'une cette paire de la démocratie et de
la liberté d'émettre et de recevoir des
idées et des informations et donc ce
fait jour une nouvelle demande qui est
je dirais dans l'idée même d'utiliser ce
droit comme un auxiliaire de la vie
démocratique et du débat d'idées de la
liberté d'informer ce qui pousse la CADA
inspiré par la jurisprudence européenne
mais aussi du Conseil d'État à faire une
balance entre les intérêts en présence
dans quel but le document est demandé
va-t-il être utilisé pour justement le
débat d'idées et la vie démocratique
quelle est la nature de celui qui le
demande dans quel contexte les documents
sont-ils demandés quel est le sens de la
démarche en quelque sorte d'un côté et
de l'autre l'atteinte possible à des
intérêts protégés et cette mise en
balance est quelque chose de nouveau
puisqu'il faut peser d'un côté l'intérêt
pour la démocratie de l'accès et de
l'autre le risque pour le fonctionnement
normal des pouvoirs publics l'un des
exemples que nous avons fait au Conseil
d'État et je présidais l'assemblée du
contentieux qui a rendu cette décision
c'est la demande d'un chercheur
qui a demandé accès aux archives
personnelles du président Mitterrand sur
les événements du Rwanda il a souhaité
pouvoir avoir accès de manière intégrale
aux notes personnelles y compris du
président Mitterrand pour comprendre je
dirais ce qui s'était passé et là nous
étions dans un cas où le président
Mitterrand avait remis ses archives
personnelles à la fin de son mandat et
le protocole prévoyait ils avaient été
inscrits ensuite dans la loi des délais
spécifiques pour pouvoir accéder à ces
archives sous le contrôle d'un
mandataire qui avait été désigné et le
Conseil d'État a jugé que l'intérêt pour
la recherche et la démarche que suivait
le demandeur d'accès c'était la loi sur
les archives qui étaient invoquée mais
c'est transposable à la Loi sur l'accès
aux documents devait primer sur la
protection du secret
de la conduite de la politique
extérieure ou la protection des intérêts
fondamentaux du pays et donc a fait
droit alors même que le délai n'était
pas écoulé à la demande d'accès
formalisée par le chercheur on voit donc
ce dont son nouvelle problématique qui
sont posées à la CADA dans cette pesée
respective des intérêts en présence je
termine peut-être en évoquant les
priorités qui pourraient être les
miennes
la CADA c'est pas seulement
facilitateur un guide c'est aussi un
avocat de la transparence il faut porter
cette cause et faire vivre faire vivre
l'équilibre voulu par législateur dans
la société d'aujourd'hui dans
l'administration d'aujourd'hui qui est
beaucoup plus numérique qui produit
beaucoup plus de documents
ma première propriété ce sera la je
dirais faire vivre cet équilibre y
compris en interprétant au vu des
nouvelles circonstances et au cas par
cas les secrets protégés par la loi en
n’hésitant pas au-delà des avis
individuels qui sont rendus sur tel ou
tel refus d'accès a publié des lignes
directrices à anticiper sur des
questions nouvelles à guider
l'administration à désamorcer des
conflits possibles à faire ce qu'on
appelle tout simplement de la prévention
pour faire naître le moins possible de
refus d'accès injustifié la deuxième
priorité c'est d'aller plus vite j'ai
parlé d'un délai moyen de 82 jours le
standard posé par la loi et d'un mois la
CADA est une petite institution elle a
17 emplois un budget de 1,5 millions
d'euros c'est une des autorités
administratives indépendantes les plus
faiblement de terre on peut s'en réjouir
pour sobriété de la dépense publique
mais c'est vrai que c'est peu pour
traiter
8500 saisines par an et faire tout le
travail que j'ai évoqué
une revalorisation des moyens et sans
doute nécessaire mais il faudra explorer
tous les moyens pour accélérer mais
surtout pour faire baisser le nombre
décisives c'est-à-dire agir par la
prévention des refus d’accès et la
pédagogie préalable la troisième
priorité c'est d'investir résolument
dans le numérique aujourd'hui les sujets
nouveaux et les sujets de demain c'est
l'accès au code source c'est l'accès aux
algorithmes c'est l'accès au programme
informatique qui commande de plus en
plus les décisions que prend
l'administration et la CADA investit de
plus en plus elle a été saisie de sujets
nouveaux par exemple en 2015 peut-on
accéder au code source qu'utilisent
l'administration fiscale pour SIM le
calcul de l'impôt sur le revenu des
personnes physiques elle a été saisie du
des de l'accès aux
aux algorithmes utilisés par l'admission
post-bac et elle a été saisie de l'accès
au code source au programme au cahier
des charges mais aussi aux algorithmes
utilisés par l'admission par le par
l'admission parcoursup dont on sait
qu'il joue un rôle important dans
l'orientation des étudiants la CADA a
rendu des avis intéressants dans
laquelle elle fait prévaloir la
transparence la publicité nécessaire de
ces codes sources et des algorithmes
parce que ce sont ces éléments là qui
commandent finalement les décisions
individuelles qui vont être prises et
les choix les sélections qui vont être
décidées mais en même temps elle est
attentive à protéger la sécurité des
systèmes d'information c'est tout un
débat en révélant les failles les
insuffisances est-ce que on ne peut pas
encourager des utilisations
malveillantes et mettre en danger la
sécurité de système d'information
personnellement je crois que dans les
choix il faut toujours préféré la
transparence à l'obscurité et que dire
la vérité est souvent bien meilleure que
cacher des failles qui de toute façon
seront révélés et donc dans ce débat
avec le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur la CADA a joué un rôle actif
et je crois
utile pour convaincre le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur qu'il fallait
d'abord réparer les failles pour avoir
un système sûr crédible et ensuite jouer
sur la confiance et la transparence
enfin l'une des priorités c'est de ne
pas seulement rendre des avis depuis
Paris c'est aussi animé un réseau
territorial comme je le disais les
administrations les collectivités
doivent désigner des personnes
responsables en leur sein qui doivent
accompagner les décideurs aussi être
l'interface avec les citoyens guidés
accompagnés au jour le jour or ceux ce
réseau des personnes responsables
pas vraiment animé aujourd'hui
les personnes sont nommées mais sont
laissés un peu à leur libre arbitre
elles n'ont pas le sentiment
d'appartenir à un réseau d'être formé
d'être accompagné d'être informé même
des évolutions de la doctrine de la CADA
je compte aller beaucoup plus sur le
terrain rencontrer les responsables
publics animés ce réseau est des
personnes responsables pour faire vivre
aussi la loi sur le terrain et faire en
sorte que cette garantie de l'accès soit
effective et ressentie comme tel voilà
je ne vais pas m'étendre sur mon
parcours antérieur vous le connaissez il
est public j'ai voilà servi l'état
pendant 44 ans je ne l'ai jamais quitté
je n'ai jamais quitté le service de
l'État depuis que j'y suis entré 1er
janvier 1976 jusqu'au départ à la
retraite en janvier de cette année j'ai
toujours refusé les propositions d'aller
dans le privé j'en ai reçu je les ai
toutes refusé je n'ai pas voulu non plus
et je le reconnais ça a été une chose à
laquelle je me suis tenu m'engager sur
le plan politique j'ai également refusé
les propositions qui ont pu mettre y
compris d'entrer dans les cabinets
ministériel parce que j'ai voulu avant
tout fondé ma carrière sur la compétence
l'indépendance l'impartialité et je m'y
suis tenu je ne l'ai pas regretté voilà
maintenant que j'ai plus de temps voilà
que maintenant que j'ai plus de temps je
souhaite m'engager à nouveau pour cette
cause de la transparence dont je suis
prêt à vous parler je suis prêt à y
mettre voilà toute mon énergie et mon
expérience et à revenir devant vous pour
rendre compte évidemment de ce que
j'aurais fait à la tête de cette
autorité si le mandat m'est confié je
vous remercie de votre écoute
merci monsieur le Président alors j'ai
plusieurs demandes de parole de
collègues monsieur Kero je me
semble-t-il monsieur Richard puis
monsieur Leconte merci monsieur le
Président de la Gontrie monsieur
Lasserre vous avez vous avez parlé de
transparence mais
on est tous au courant ici dans cette
commission et sans revenir sur le fond
de de la faire de votre renvoi devant le
tribunal correctionnel encore une fois
il nous appartient pas de nous prononcer
sur une démarche qui est une démarche
de l'autorité de l'autorité judiciaire
pour autant et c'est ma question ne
pensez-vous pas que la situation dans
laquelle vous vous trouvez
risque d'avoir des effets tout
simplement sur l'institution que vous
vous proposez éventuellement de présider
c'est ma première question
ma deuxième est peut-être un petit peu
plus brutale
vous avez quitté le Conseil d'État après
effectivement une longue et belle
carrière remarquable de serviteurs de
l'État vous l'avez quitté à 68 ans parce
que c'est l'âge légal j'allais dire
maximum or il s'avère que à la CADA il y
a pas de il y a pas de limite d'âge
c'est sans doute
je ne sais pas quelque chose qui est
coïncidence ou je sais pas comment le
qualifier mais ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
est assez étonnant de prendre la
présidence d'une institution alors que
vous êtes à la retraite et que par
ailleurs vous avez justement
été à la retraite parce que vous avez
atteint la limite qui est celle de la de
la haute de la haute fonction de la
haute fonction publique vous présenter
cette activité comme une activité
complémentaire de la retraite vous
comprendrez que je m'étonne de cette
présentation je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Richard
oui
je voudrais poser la question à Bruno
Lasserre de savoir s'il veut revenir
nous voir
je parle d'un oui d'accord faut que je
me penche un peu
il me semble avoir noté différentes
reprises que la CADA pouvait regretter
de ne pas avoir ils ont des procédures
de mise en demeure ou des procédures de
d'intervention en quelque sorte pour
accélérer les temps de réponse des
administrations et lever des obstacles
lorsque je pense en particulier parce
que ça devient une partie tout de même
importante du champ d'intervention de la
CADA les autorités locales avec souvent
un contexte politique un peu conflictuel
donc
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait le bilan
des outils procédureaux dont dispose la
cadavre pour
pousser à la
surmonter disons des refuses
communication qui sont problématiques et
donc est-ce que vous pensez
éventuellement faire des propositions de
modification parce que on est tout de
suite dans le législatif sur ce point là
et pour aller dans le sens de ce que
vous avez décrit tout à l'heure je veux
aussi citer moi une découverte que j'ai
faite il y a peu de temps alors que
j'aurais sans doute dû la faire un peu
plus tôt qui était la place prise dans
la gestion de tous les établissements y
compris primaires de l'éducation
nationale
d'un indice de position sociale
qui a été élaboré au sein du ministère
par des sociologues
et dont il est rigoureusement impossible
de connaître la configuration
j'ai pris conscience de la l'importance
qu'avait sur les sur les choix
d'attribution de moyens et maintenant
aussi sur les choix de destination des
élèves
c'est indice de position sociale qui
englobe la situation
assez
individuelle presque intime de chaque
famille
lorsque j'ai demandé à l'administration
de l'éducation nationale de connaître la
façon puisque on peut être plus ou moins
maniaque de statistiques moi je suis
assez fortement atteint de savoir
comment était fabriqué c'est indice on
m'a renvoyé vers un article de revue de
sociologie
édité écrit par l'auteur principal de du
système qui évidemment une auto
justification particulièrement brillante
mais qui ne permet absolument pas de
comprendre pourquoi dans l'école de 50
élèves de tel ou tel village l'indice de
position sociale moyen de ces 50 élèves
et de temps donc il me semble qu'il
reste je crois d'ailleurs qu'il y a une
saisine de la CADA récemment sur ce
sujet et ma dent je crois la parent
d'élève tout simplement mais qui
démontre une
détermination du ministère d'éducation
nationale qu'on n'aurait jamais
le plus suspecté d'une telle démarche de
rétention de l'information sur des
sujets clés
merci Monsieur Leconte
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président une lorsque une
administration
ne se soumet pas un avis de la cadavre
ce sont les juridictions juridictions
administratives qui
traite le cas échéant les demandes de
recours
voilà dans vos fonctions au Conseil
d'État vous avez dû en voir passer
est-ce que vous pensez que compte tenu
du rôle que vous avez eu sur un certain
nombre de ces dossiers est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un peu comment vous
abordez ce nouveau rôle alors que vous
avez vous quitté celui qui a jugé la
cadavre finalement et l'administration
merci et Madame de La Gontrie
merci merci président
dans le prolongement de la question
d'Eric Kerrouche concernant votre
situation personnelle je pense que il
faut bien que vous compreniez que c'est
l'institution qui nous intéresse
et non votre votre propre situation et
nous a pas échappé que la procédure est
peut-être encore en cours même si il
faut le rappeler dans l'affaire qui dont
il s'agit l'État a été condamné pour
Foot lourde mais ce qui m'intrigue c'est
c'est la cohérence avec les décisions du
Conseil
puisque dans une affaire Mathieu Gallet
en 2018
vous aviez vous le conseiller d'État lié
le principe d'exemplarité des dirigeants
publics à l'objectif de confiance des
administrer je veux pas dire les
considérant mais
indiquant que les questions déontologie
et de moralisation de la vie publique
sont des préoccupations particulièrement
fortes bref
donc c'est cela qui est un point me
semble-t-il délicat
par rapport à cette à cette proposition
de de nomination c'est
nécessairement la lecture qui sera
donnée du fait que finalement ce type
d'affaires n'ont pas grand importance
puisque elle n'empêche pas aux
fonctionnaires au magistrat ce que vous
êtes incontestablement de poursuivre une
carrière prestigieuse donc c'est voilà
c'est c'est tout cela et j'ai lu les
réponses que vous avez fait aux
questionnaire mais qui évoquent voilà
mais sur cet aspect là comment vous
vivez vous ça est-ce que ça veut dire
que si vous deviez être condamné je sais
très bien que vous n'êtes pas renvoyé
pour l'instant donc voilà quel serait
votre décision comment comment est-ce
que vous arrivez à rendre compatible
avec l'exigence que vous avez manifesté
et dont je ne dis ce qu'on vient pas de
la qualité de votre service
merci y a-t-il d'autres questions
il n'y a pas d'autres monsieur
avec votre autorisation je vais répondre
d'abord à Monsieur kerouche et Madame de
La Gontrie abordé directement cette
affaire et
vous en parler
j'ai présidé l'Autorité de la
concurrence de 2004 à 2016 pendant 12
ans je suis venu à trois reprises
d'ailleurs devant le Sénat pour je
dirais défendre le mandat qui m'a été
confiée par trois présidents de la
République successifs et il me semble
que à l'époque j'avais obtenu
l'unanimité aussi bien à l'Assemblée
qu'au Sénat j'ai beaucoup développé
cette institution n’hésitant pas avec
courage je crois à témérité à affronter
les intérêts puissants à plusieurs
milliards de sanctions ont été
prononcées à l'égard d'entreprise pour
des cartels secrets des ententes de prix
des abus de position dominante j'ai
porté pendant 12 ans cette cause
l'affaire est née
de méthodes de management qui ont été
mises en place dans un service de
l'autorité qui dépendait du président le
service juridique il y a eu trois chefs
du service juridique pendant les 12 ans
que j'ai tenu à la tête de l'Autorité de
la concurrence une première magistrate
pendant 7 ans tout s'est bien passé
un chef de service j'y reviendrai qui
est lui accusé à titre principal de
harcèlement moral puis un autre chef de
service magistrat avec lequel tout s'est
bien passé
en septembre 2019
j'ai été alors que j'étais
vice-président du Conseil d'État mise en
examen par deux juges instructions du
tribunal de grande instance de Paris
pour complicité de harcèlement moral et
je voudrais tout de suite parce que les
réseaux sociaux les blogs se sont
emparés de tout cela on a confondu les
choses en disant monsieur Lasserre Arcel
son personnel non personne ne soutient
dans ce dossier que j'ai pu tenir le
moindre propos malveillant ou agit de
manière malveillante à l'égard de
quiconque on ne me reproche pas un
management ou des agissements
caractérisés de harcèlement moral ce
qu'on me reproche et je vais expliquer
que je suis en profond désaccord avec
cette analyse c'est en tant que
président et dans l'exercice de mes
pouvoirs de direction de cette autorité
indépendante de ne pas avoir mis fin aux
fonctions du chef de service qui est lui
accusé à titre principal de harcèlement
morale et donc ça n'est pas mon
intégrité qui est en cause ça n'est pas
le respect comme dans l'affaire galet
des règles des marchés publics c'est la
façon dont j'ai présidé cette
institution et comme tout employeur le
retard que j'aurais mis une fois que
j'aurais été informé à mettre fin aux
fonctions du chef de service concerné
cette analyse là je la réfute
entièrement j'ai été informé à la fin du
mois de janvier
2013 par le médecin de prévention quand
j'ai su qu'il allait m'appeler ces mêmes
moi qui ai pris les devants pour
l'appeler moi-même dès le lendemain de
cet appel il ne faisait pas état de
harcèlement moral mais il faisait pas de
correction multiples et exagérées et
inutilement avec sa toile mise en place
par ce chef de service j'ai réuni dès le
lendemain le service avec les syndicats
pour comprendre ce qui se passait
quelques jours plus tard nous avons
réuni le comité d'hygiène et de sécurité
la demande a été faite d'un audit pour
savoir ce qui se passait et c'est
moi-même qui est soutenu le principe de
cette audit menée par une société
extérieure pour permettre aux agents de
se livrer de manière libre en quelque
sorte et de dire de manière libre ce
qu'il pensait de la situation
dans les huit jours qui ont suivi la
remise de ce rapport qui parlait de
management toxiques et disqualifiant
j'ai mis fin aux fonctions du chef de
service et les choses se sont
arrêtés là non parce que quelques mois
plus tard mais alors qu'il n'était plus
sous l'autorité non ce n'est pas un
suicide il a été retrouvé mort à son
dossier mais la famille elle-même réfute
le terme de suicide cette affaire m'a
bouleversé comme beaucoup de personnes
au sein de l'autorité mais je le dis et
je l'ai écrit aux membres et aux agents
du Conseil d'État à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur au syndicat et au président
de tribunaux de cours administrative
d'appel je réfute avec la totale énergie
l'idée même de complicité dès que j'ai
su j'ai fermement condamné les méthodes
de management que je n'avais pas mis en
place ni même demander de mettre en
place et la meilleure preuve que je me
suis décelé dérisé immédiatement de ces
méthodes c'est que j'ai mis fin aux
fonctions du chef de service concerné
donc pour moi le terme de complicité oui
je le trouve injuste inexact contraire à
la chronologie des faits et à ce que
j'ai fait et je la conteste et je
continuerai si je suis renvoyé devant le
tribunal à contesté avec toute mon
énergie cette accusation j'ai 44 ans de
service de l'État j'ai dirigé des
directions de ministères des chambres
contentieuses conseils d'état des
sections des autorités indépendantes
personne ne garde comment
le fait que dans toutes les fonctions
que j'ai exercées et à chaque fois j'ai
impulsé des réformes des changements des
transformations j'ai pu manquer de
respect ou de bienveillance vis-à-vis
des autres ou j'ai mis en place un
management qui n'est pas celui qu'on
attend d'un responsable public la
meilleure preuve que je peux faire face
à cette accusation et au risque d'un
procès sans entamer ma sérénité et mon
indépendance c'est que lorsque cette
mise en examen que j'ai annoncé moi-même
j'ai pris les devants pour l'annoncer
moi-même avant que la presse n'en fasse
état j'ai reçu un énorme élan de soutien
au sein du Conseil d'État et on peut le
dire pendant les quatre années qui ont
été celles de moments-là quand on était
des années difficiles parce que c'est
les années de Christ sanitaire ou le
Conseil d'État n'a jamais été autant
mobilisé par les référés je dirais
urgent l'examen de textes très plus
nombreux qu'il a fallu souvent examiner
en moins de deux jours en moins de trois
jours nous avons été sur le pont pendant
tous ces mois difficiles le baromètre
social n'a jamais montré une adhésion
aussi forte au management du Conseil
d'État et de sa direction plus de 90 %
c'est un chiffre considérable et les
gens ont été interrogés par une société
extérieure plus de 80% des membres et
des agents ont considéré que le Conseil
d'État avait été bien managé pendant
cette époque et on fait preuve de leur
adhésion y compris à mon égard nous
n'avons jamais autant fait en matière
sociale en matière de dialogue social en
matière de signature d'accord sur
l'égalité professionnelle d'initiatives
innovantes en matière de ressources
humaines et de ce point de vue là oui je
suis fier du bilan social que j'ai mis
en place au sein du Conseil d'État et
donc oui je ferai face parce que je
conteste cette accusation je la trouve
inexact je la trouve injuste je la
trouve pas conforme au fait c'est la vie
on est parfois confronté à ses épreuves
c'est une épreuve pour moi je la vis je
la vis comme telle mais je ferai face et
ce n'entendra en rien ni mon énergie ni
la confiance ni la confiance ni la
confiance que peut placer le public
dans un responsable d'une autorité
administrative si c'est un apparente tu
as aimé la confiance en tant que
vice-président et donc responsable à la
tête d'une institution comme le Conseil
d'État je vois mal comment cela pourrait
entamer la confiance dans une autorité
comme la CADA
sur l'âge écoutez moi je suis un peu
désolé la loi ne prévoit pas de limite
d'âge pour ce poste là je alors
dites-moi si je parie diminuer ou
presque gâteux
fonder sur l'âge je n'ai pas le
sentiment je n'ai pas le CADA a été dans
le passé présidé par des personnes à
l'activité présidées par des personnes à
la retraite dans les deux cas je crois
que cela a bien marché difficile de
faire un procès parce qu'on a 68 ans sur
le fait qu'on n'est pas capable de
diriger une institution comme celle-là
en tout cas je ne suis pas me
semble-t-il
en état de dire que je n'ai pas les
capacités l'énergie la santé pour
pouvoir diriger efficacement et porter
des ambitions à la tête de cette
institution
je voudrais répondre sur les
la question du sénateur à la Richard
faut-il aller plus loin faut-il aller
plus loin dans les outils dont dispose
la CADA et notamment lui donner un
pouvoir d'ajonction en quelque sorte qui
forcerait l'administration à suivre ses
avis je ne suis pas favorable pour deux
raisons d'abord parce qu'aujourd'hui je
trouve que la transparence doit être
d'abord l'affaire des administrations et
le fait de devoir prendre une nouvelle
décision éclairée par la vie de la CADA
mais prendre la décision soi-même est
une chose importante de pas se défausser
sur une autorité indépendante mais être
responsable de la transparence et la
portée si l'on donnait à la CADA et
c'est le second obstacle un pouvoir
d'injonction cela voudrait dire que ses
avis se transformeraient en quasi
décision elles auraient être une force
obligatoire et donc serait susceptible
de recours et ce serait la CADA qui
devrait elle-même
défendre ses avis devant la juridiction
administrative à la place de
l'administration compte tenu des faibles
moyens dont elles dispose je ne suis pas
sûr que cela lui rendrait service je
crois qu'elle doit être un pédagogue
quelqu'un qui est clair qui aide
l'administration à prendre la bonne
décision mais pas forcément celle qui
décide qui décide à sa place sur la
question concernant l'éducation
nationale vous avez raison dès lors que
on classe on répertorie on trie un
certain nombre d'informations pour
mesurer la position sociale des familles
ces familles en droit à savoir quels
sont les méthodes algorithmes les codes
sources utilisés pour classer les
personnes les familles dans la position
sociale qui est la leur et donc la règle
devrait être l'ouverture et la publicité
et comme vous l'avez dit la CADA c'est
prononcé dans ce sens
monsieur le compte a posé la question
des tribunaux administratifs et une fine
et du Conseil d'État juge suprême dans
la communicabilité des documents je
crois qu'il y a pas de contradiction
c'est souvent la jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État qui oriente les choses
puisqu'il dit le droit de manière
définitive et la CADA doit souvent très
souvent en quelque sorte inspirer ses
avis par les décisions que prend le
Conseil d'État et donc connaître cette
jurisprudence éventuellement mais en
tant que vice-président je n'ai pas
vraiment participé aux décisions
contentieuses je siégé rarement mais les
connaître cette jurisprudence me semble
plutôt un avantage
voilà les réponses que je pouvais
apporter mais je suis évidemment à la
disposition des sénateurs et des
sénatrices il y en avait d'autres chez
Richard
que vous étiez également président de la
commission des transferts
la commission de participation des
transferts
gère des informations très spécifiques
couverte par des
protections légales notamment qui
touchent au droit des droits des
affaires et donc
comment prévoyez-vous de recevoir
en tant que président de cette autorité
indépendante des
critiques ou des demandes émanant
soit l'observateur soit de forces
économique sur une position prise au
sein de la commission qui si je me
trompe n'a qu'un roule consultatif mais
un constant rôle consultatif décisif
depuis 40 ans
alors la Commission des participations
et des transferts et le nouveau nom
donné à l'ex-Commission des
privatisations qui avait été mise en
place en 1986 pour évaluer de manière
indépendante les entreprises ou les
actifs que c'est de l'État soient par
des privatisations soit par des sessions
de gré à gré et comme le dit le sénateur
Richard la CPT la Commission des
participations et des transferts donnent
un avis qui lit l'administration le plus
souvent sur le prix auquel l'entreprise
doit être vendue elle fixe en quelque
sorte le prix plancher en deçà duquel
l'état où les entreprises publiques ne
peuvent pas vendre alors évidemment
comme vous le dites il y a beaucoup
d'informations confidentielles qui sont
communiqués à la commission des
participations et des et des et des
transferts et si des demandes d'accès
étaient présentées il est bien sûr que
je ne siègerai pas en tant que président
de la CADA de même que je ne siègerai
pas si j'avais le moindre conflit
d'intérêt avec des fonctions que j'ai pu
occuper dans le passé voilà
merci monsieur le Président pour tous
monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Lasserre une question à vous poser
instruit des faits qui ont été évoqués
tout à l'heure sur lesquels je ne
reviendrai pas sur le fond si vous
veniez à être désigné à la présidence de
la CADA quel procès c'est quels outils
quelle méthodologie ou comptez mettre en
oeuvre pour éviter que ces félins ne
puissent pas se reproduire et que ne
puisse pas être reproché à des
collaborateurs à des subalterne qui
travailleraient dans vos équipes et sous
vos ordres
alors la CADA est une petite institution
c'est 16 personnes 17 personnes
exactement
les rapports sont très confiants très
bienveillants mais monsieur le sénateur
j'ai présidé beaucoup d'institutions et
je n'ai jamais eu la réputation d'un
tyran jamais je n'ai jamais eu cette
réputation là je crois que je suis
proche des gens m'apporte est ouverte
j'essaie d'écouter et surtout
d'embarquer les équipes avec moi pour
les pour impulser les réformes chaque
fois que la République m'a confié un
mandat que ce soit dans les télécoms que
ce soit dans la concurrence que ce soit
la tête du Conseil d'État j'ai modifié
les choses j'ai été artisan de réforme
de transformation profonde je l'ai
toujours fait en association avec les
parties prenantes mais aussi le
personnel et je crois profondément là à
ces méthodes de management qui reposent
sur la confiance sur l'écoute sur voilà
tout simplement la simplicité des
rapports entre nous et le personnel de
la CADA je peux vous le dire n'a aucune
inquiétude de ce côté-là
merci monsieur le Président il n'y a pas
d'autres questions donc je vous remercie
de votre présence des propos
naturellement des informations que vous
nous avez donné et je demande aux
collègues de rester car nous allons
désormais procéder au vote merci
beaucoup